Eric asks need your advice on getting
the first 10 customers for a creative
service startup we make product videos
for online retailers Eric I once made a
video and let's link this up down here
below and let's put it up right here can
you can you guys make another video move
in here is it just gonna be a still shot
yeah if it's on YouTube we can make it
look beautiful the famous video I made
where I cold call people for customers
right and it was something people really
loved then that's my answer to get the
first 10 customers you have to grind
sorry D Rock and I screwed up your but
you have to grind what I mean by
grinding is you have to just reach out
to every single person like you just
have to roll up on people I mean like
hey will you buy my stuff there was one
customer so I was awesome did you catch
her in the background or doubt I mean
you just have to ask so go to every
single person in the world that will
possibly buy your thing and ask them to
buy your thing
you